janosch weißt du noch wie wir uns
kennengelernt haben ja klar weiß ich ist
das war in diesem medienzentrum in
münster und du bist mir deine
freundinnen gekommen um irgendein
projekt zu besprechen und dann hast du
bei dem erzähl bei dem erzählen immer so
gemacht
und ich fand das strange lake das was
ist das denn und ich erinnere mich noch
am ende des treffens hast du mir werden
e mail adresse gegeben und die war jan
haben for you mit einem drittel
aufkleber kleinen comic aufkleber und da
dachte ich was
ich war schon damals ziemlich cool ja
heute fragen wir mal hier auf der straße
in berlin paare wie sie sich
kennengelernt haben los gehts los geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie habt ihr euch kennengelernt
fahrgemeinschaften ich habe ihn immer
mit sony genommen ich hatte ein auto
damals man habe ihn immer mitgenommen
und darüber haben uns kennengelernt
ja genau bei einer mitfahrgelegenheit
dann sind wir zusammen gefahren ins
gespräch gekommen und dann deutschland
in die niederlande sind wir mal gefahren
weil wir den niederlanden studiert haben
wir haben uns kennengelernt weil wir
immer denselben kneipen waren und dann
haben wir uns getroffen und weil wir
dieselbe musik worden und was war das
filmen musik und menschen
ja eher das ist aber auch schon fast 30
jahre her aber
mögen wir immer noch
in der psychiatrie
war die patientin oder ärzten bei der
arbeit gut zu sagen also als
professionelle wie habt ihr euch
kennengelernt im auto zwischen berlin
und hamburg und wie sehr schön
oft in
genau die neue
h
man sich heutzutage ganz klassisch
kennenlernt über das internet
kinder
friendscout ist die seite und wie lange
seid ihr jetzt schon ein paar
das ist toll ich habe studiert mit einem
schulfreund von meinem jetzigen mann
beim feiern wir haben uns beim feiern
kennengelernt was habt ihr gefeilt im
club
[Musik]
welche welche welches teil welche musik
techno musik so
wie in der kneipe ja empfiehlt das
weinschenke
also nichts besonderes ganz klar anders
gestern
für knapp 2
ja wie habt ihr euch kennengelernt und
das auf eine lange geschichte
bin bereit ok
vor 25 jahren
ja kann ich bestätigen das stimmt ich
war geschieden ich habe sie auch und
mein sohn war ein bisschen traurig weil
wir wenig kontakt hatten weil er bei
seiner mutter lebte und er bat mich an
einer klassenfahrt teilzunehmen als als
elternvertreter mit der lehrerin
zusammen die kinder zu betreuen und um
einen so mein sohn ging in dieselbe
klasse wie sein sohn und mein sohn hat
dann auf dieser klassenfahrt ihnen so
toll gefunden weil er gitarre spielen
kann und dann kam mein sohn nach hause
von der klassenfahrt und sagte oder war
der vater von matthias der roller
für dich nein er wollte dann gitarre
spielen lernen meinte ja und so hat sich
das dann entwickelt da haben wir uns
durch gitter gehört und du hast ja bald
geburtstag wenn deine mutter die in den
geschenken dann kriegt ihr das bei genau
so kam das so muss sich dahin
und so haben wir uns kennengelernt wie
habt ihr euch kennengelernt
wie lange habt ihr zeit
einfach ok du fängst du fängst du fängst
wir haben viel gelernt in einer puppe in
aus boston
ich war damals ein
singen und er war trug zwei schlagzeuge
und er war aus berlin gekommen zum
boston und ja das war es das ist
natürlich auch so ungefähr das war da
hatten genau das war unser erstes
treffen das war eine berliner band die
aber nach amerika übergesiedelt ist
umgesiedelt ist und sie kamen dazu wir
hatten ein paar konzerte haben uns
eigentlich verliebt ineinander aber ist
durfte noch nicht sein zu jener zeit
und ich bin dann zurück nach berlin hat
mein leben hier gelebt sie hat ihr leben
gelebt und vor drei jahren haben wir uns
über facebook wiedergetroffen und kennen
und neu kennengelernt wie schön ist da
und sie haben 21 ja nach 21 jahren
zusammen und diese wochenende ist unsere
[Musik]
wir freuen uns mit euch danke schön
zeit für eine kleine pause und zeit für
euch den sponsor unseres heutigen videos
kennen zu lernen und das sind unsere
freunde von seal engen ihr habt bestimmt
schon von zielen gehört es ist eine app
zum deutsch lernen an der wir sogar
mitgearbeitet haben und heute möchte ich
euch mal die trivia section auf sieht
lang zeigen das ist eigentlich eine
quizshow in der ihr live gegen andere
teilnehmer spielen könnt und euer
deutsch direkt testen könnt es gibt
verschiedene levels von a1 bis b2
ihr könnt also ganz einfach einsteigen
und dann das fortgeschrittene level
spielen und ihr könnt dort fragen
beantworten zur deutschen sprache und
zum allgemeinwissen über deutschland
probiert das mal aus dann testet ihr
auch eure reaktionsfähigkeit im
deutschen und verbessert so ganz
natürlich und mit ganz viel spaß hat
deutsch viel spaß damit
[Musik]
und wie lange kennt ihr euch jetzt fast
sieben jahre
schon ganz schön lange wir sind auch
verheiratet seit diesem jahr
war das eine liebe auf den ersten blick
kann man so nicht sagen
es hat etwas gedauert aber die zuneigung
ballon und erzählen sie ein bisschen
damit hat das angefangen wie hat das
angefangen dass wir uns gestritten haben
bei der arbeit und aber festgestellt
haben dass wir uns als kinder schon
gekannt haben oder uns begegnet sind
ja und dann haben wir uns bei der arbeit
eben öfters gesehen man merkt dass damit
keine abneigung da ist sondern zuneigung
wir haben uns in der freizeit öftern
getroffen so kam eins zum anderen war
dass die liebe auf den ersten blick
ja ja ja ja
schön war es war eine gute gute vater
machte 2009 einen
kleinen erfolg gibt uns recht
war das eine liebe auf den ersten blick
wir kannten uns schon vorher vom sehen
und so wurde das dann immer wieder tief
nein nicht der erste blick
[Gelächter]
das hat noch gedauert ein bisschen
ungefähr nach zwei monaten wurden wir
dann zusammen was fandest du
faszinierend an ihm
sie ist sehr
expressiv sie oder ich will von berlin
oder man immer ein deutsches nicht sehr
gut
das machten sie habe sehr extravagant
auf strahlend und wann ist die
klargeworden dass diese
fahrgemeinschaften auch eine beziehung
entstehen könnte das war eigentlich bei
einer bestimmten pfad wurde dann im stau
standen und uns dann das erstmal ganz
lange unterhalten haben und seitdem bei
der nicht weiß glaube ich uns beiden
klar dass er mehr daraus werden könnte
oder mehr daraus wird und genau und wann
ist es ihnen klar geworden dass mit
diesen menschen will ich hart druck und
metal weiterhin
nach den ersten abend die wir zu zweit
zusammen verbracht haben na ja das geht
ganz schnell und wie lange hat das
ungefähr gedauert wie lange war das nur
so eine lose beziehung und
da sehen wir uns nicht einig das ist
interessant
spätestens am 3 4 jahren zusammen
darauf können wir uns da können wir uns
einigen aber so drei monate sind wir
bestimmt auseinander und was liebt ihr
euch aneinander was liebst du an ihm
sie hatten also
ich einfach alles einfach alles auch
wenn ich bin
irgendwie arm ja
weißt du die kleine sache in beziehung
dass man nach und das nervt und manchmal
habe ich das gefühl dass ort das nicht
aber wenn ich sein gesicht sie denn ich
alles was und ich bin total verliebt
nochmals ist sie immer du hast die
gleiche waffe die ich einsätze du siehst
unschuldig aus der
es wirklich egal was ich meinen neuen
betrag
danke er will was ich verspreche ich
versuche immer unschuldig dabei
auszusehen und
was schätzt du was ich an die schätze
ihre liebenswürdigkeit tatsächlich
also sich ruhige angenehme freundliche
nicht aufgeregt
ich schätze sein humor das ist schön mit
ihm lachen kann seine entspanntheit
seine lässigkeit und habt ihr jetzt eine
bands zusammen wir machen musik klar
warum ich den gitarristen eine gute
frage
ist ja kein salz mehr macht man sich ja
wir lieben popmusik ja als übergeordnete
musikrichtungen klammer wir gehen in
alle richtungen und ich möchte euch auf
jeden fall finden können irgendwo falls
ihr irgendwo ein konzept gibt dann bin
ich in der ersten reihe sehr schön du
hast ja du bist ja verbunden und damit
ein deutsch weil wir sprechen immer
englisch ja und das ist
drei jahre
keine durch kunden und dem conti hatte
ich das gefühl ich muss das machen und
wie macht man das und dann habe ich die
siedlungen gefunden und war so und jeder
podcast nicht mit meiner happens und
kochen oder kürzen oder sowas und ich
höre kari und manuel quatschen oder was
auch immer
und das ist ja schon
liebe es jetzt wollen wir von euch
wissen wie habt ihr denn euren partner
oder ihre partnerin kennen gelernt und
wie hat sich dann eure beziehung
entwickelt schreibt uns doch mal einen
kommentar auf deutsch denn das
interessiert uns und dann könnt ihr auch
euer deutsch lernen und wenn ihr lust
habt das vokabular von heute noch einmal
zu wiederholen
dann werdet gerne ein mitglied von easy
jaren hier vorne blenden wir jetzt
gleich den button 1 über den ihr ein
mitglied werden könnte und dann kriegt
ihr speziell zu dieser episode noch mal
ein interaktives übungs blatt das easy
und eric für euch vorbereitet tschüss
bis bald
[Musik]